con apenas tres años de experiencia ana
periodista del medio digital nac y pelo
no se imaginó que se convertiría en una
reportera de guerra y que además sería
una de las dos periodistas de su diario
que no abandonaron su ciudad durante el
conflicto y
la mayoría de la gente de mi redacción
huyó al principio de la guerra para
poner a salvo a sus familias
y colegas lejos a la lleva meses
durmiendo y trabajando en este sótano
donde ahora está ubicada la redacción
mantener la serenidad para seguir
informando es un gran reto
de hecho chan trabajo cuando antes lo
más difícil es mantener bajo control la
ansiedad y controlar las emociones para
trabajar contando las historias de los
que sufren
colega colega de anna dejó su trabajo
como fotógrafo de eventos comerciales
para dedicarse a la crónica de guerra
dice que quiere mostrar al mundo lo que
está ocurriendo en su país y se prepara
para lo peor con cursos de primeros
auxilios
si me siento a salvo mi papá ha estado
luchando desde el comienzo de la guerra
se siente y la sal muchos
reporteros sin fronteras ha documentado
la muerte de ocho periodistas del
comienzo del conflicto en ucrania una
cifra que ucrania eleva hasta los
treinta incluyendo aquellos reporteros
que se afiliaron para combatir usaban
instructor de supervivencia de
conflictos explica que muchos
periodistas fallecen porque no saben qué
hacer o se trata de casos desesperados
artístico
y las estadísticas dicen que la mayoría
de los fallecimientos se producen por
hemorragias masivas no controladas
o le guían a no tienen intención de
dejar de momento la ciudad son jóvenes
reporteros que quieren crecer y hacer
carrera en el trabajo de campo más duro
la guerra